So we started off today with gPU programming and we're now moving on to compilers nice
Um my name is Francisca Hinkelman. I'm a software engineer on the Chrome V8 team
I'm also a node.js core collaborator and I talk about Profiling V8. I
Think we can all agree that Javascript is incredibly powerful like not only in what it can do
But also in how fast it can do it
it's amazing that the Javascript a
Scripting language you can run enterprise note service
And you can run websites with these huge complex frameworks like a Facebook website or linkedin or YouTube and all that was a scripting language
and
the performance of Javascript, or
the possibility to run such huge applications with Javascript of course comes down to the
Javascript engines the virtual machines that take your source code and turn it into an executable
Machine code make your website dynamic um so in this start, we'll look at V8
that's the Javascript engine in Chrome and
What it does to make Javascript so fast and how you can profile these optimizations?
So to put V8 into context the eight is not the only Javascript engine
The the Major Browsers all have their own Javascript engine we have check of our core that is in
Microsoft Edge you might have heard kind of talk yesterday. We have Javascript core and Safari
We have spider monkey and various other monkeys and firefox and we have V8 in chrome
If you're familiar with nodejs that also runs with a javascript engine your default node comes with V8
but you can also build it with Jack Krak for
Electron refer talks about electrons and status
Chromium and nodejs it has a V8 instance
And then there's other engines that are smaller if you took yun talks there
They are very good for iot devices because they're much much smaller
They are not as fast as the big ones, but you can fit them on your little micro controllers
So duct tape or Javascript are examples there
in
In order to talk successfully about program about profiling
In this talk will look a little bit of some of the internal key concepts of V8
So I'm hoping to give you some insight into this black box um
what we eight is doing under the hood how you go from
Source code to really fast machine code
And I'll show you some some tools. How you can Profile V8
so not profile Javascript on A
Higher level that would be probably more useful if you want the first performance gains
But really down at the Low level compiler level Javascript engine
The the tools I'm showing you on the one hand. They're tools that we use internally at V8
So if we want to make it faster if we want to figure out, why something slow, what is slow?
Yeah, those are the tools we use and then we change we ade internally to make it faster
but of course you can also use these tools to compile to profile your code and
Maybe make some changes there to gain performance
If you've used the chrome dev tools you might have seen there is a profile tab
So you have two console and you can inspect your hTML and css, but there's also a profile
profile Tab where you can record cPU profiles or heap snapshots and
When you do that for Javascript, or you can also do it for node.js server application?
You you start your app you load your website
You start recording after while you stop it? And then you you get a profile of which functions are being run a lot
So I did this year for compiling some typescript you see which function is spent
time being spent on but one thing you see he unfortunately is this little exclamation mark
Which of course means some kind of trouble?
In this case the function is related to gets a warning from the profiler saying not optimized and the reason is
optimized too many times
so the next
22 minutes, I want to dig into what does this optimization mean?
What are we trying to optimize and why is this not happening or possible in this case?
so
Let's start with some fundamentals. I guess um
Javascript is dynamically typed. It's not statically typed like C++. Or what you have arrest
It's dynamically typed that means the types of your variables can change all the time and the compiler
only influenced at runtime
What?
What kind of object or type it has it doesn't know that when I just sees the swiss code?
um
Here's a very simple example. It's an object defined as an object literal
X is 1 and y is 1 do you know what the properties of this object are I?
Mean it's it's very obvious x and y clearly our properties
But are they do the only properties know this object also gets all the properties of the object
Prototype or if you change the prototype it would get all the properties of that new prototype
Ok so we figure out properties are x and y and everything from the prototype chain can the compiler rely on this information?
No, because you can at any time delete properties of an object
So this object that you have can change all the time and only at runtime can the compiler say yes?
It has an x yes. It has y or not
And of course you can also add properties
So this type information is not available up front it's it's dynamic and the compiler always has to infer it
and
So since Java Script is dynamically typed. What all the
Modern Javascript engines do those that care about performance those that we use under browsers
Not necessarily on the smallest iot devices is so-called
just-in-Time compilation
So we compile as we execute a program in
C++ this is very different if you've ever done any C++. It is clearly ahead of time compilation
because you actually do two separate steps you first compile it and
You add a little bit and then you get an executable that you can run
There's no such thing in Javascript you you just run it. I mean you might
Transpile it first depending what you use, but there's no separate compilation step from the execution
But for Javascript because we don't have any type information anything can change all the time we need to do just-in-time compilation
I'm gonna look at this example a lot. It's it's super simple
it's a function that I called load and all it does it's it's
Accessing a property you wouldn't even put that in a function usually because it doesn't do much
but it's just return object that x given a parameter x and
Obviously you do property access all the time in Javascript even if you do console dot lock
Console is your object and blog as your property so it's just
Everywhere you can't do without property access and this looks super simple you have it all the time. It looks very harmless
You know what it does, but if you think about it carefully
what are all the things that could happen here as to return value well as the compiler tries to get the value object at x
um
First of all if you put an undefined as a parameter, it'll throw a type error
The object might not have two property x so it would be undefined
Or it might be that the object itself doesn't have an own property x but somewhere up the prototype chain x was defined
so the compiler would have to look up recursively the prototype chain until it finds x
Object might be a proxy so we have to call it to get handler
And x might have been defined and eggman script sic style as an exerciser script where you have to call the get function
So you can have any kind of arbitrary side effects?
So for the compiler this very simple object at x is is a lot of stuff it has to worry about
um
This is a snippet from the Acma script
specification don't be worried about reading all this, but this is how the
Ordinary get us what they call it is Define
And you can tell this is quite involved for just a tiny little object that x down here
So since we have property accesses everywhere on the program
We eight needs to do a little trick because we can't afford
To do these steps every time you do a console that log or any kind of access
So let me show you what you do
So here's the simple load function
And we call it with this very simple object that is just a regular object
no changes on the prototype chain it has one property x and it's an integer, so
When we when the compiler encounters is this call of load?
Well, we do implement
Correct atmosphere Javascript, so the compiler has to follow these steps on a specification
Which is quite involved and eventually it figures out okay? It's a value to script. I have to return this value
Which is at a certain offset of this object?
Okay, so we found object at x and now what we do is. We cache this information and
What we are caching is we're caching for
these kind of objects
This is how you get the value?
So we're not caching that specific object and the 5V caching objects that look exactly like this
simple Literal in this case
we know the
Value for x is at a constant offset to our object, so that's some V8 internal that we know where it's stored
but but we know any object that looks like this, so just one property it's called x and it's an
This is how we get to the value if we needed?
And we associate that cash with the call with this property access
So when we later in the program called load again?
We're calling it now as a different object
this one has the object x is 17 and not 5 but they look very much the same if you think about the shape of
these objects
So when we do this again, and we get to this property access um well. We're being smart now
We check the cache first to see if maybe we have already figured out how to do that um and we realize yes
We have exactly these kind of objects we have an entry full objects that look like this in the cache
so let's just get the
Offset because that is where that value is and we furr can forget about these 10 steps that otherwise. We'd have to do
Ok and um these caches the the former name is inline caches. We shortcut them to ICs
So if you have a look at the 8 source code, there's a lot of ICs everywhere
You have an IC associated to every property access
Not to the function or the object but every single access so in this case you have two
Completely separate inline caches for both these lines even though it looks the same and it's the same function
and what you store in an IC is the keys a
Shape of objects and the values are the fast path how to get that value?
So in our case
We're storing what the object looks like and we had to get to 5 or a 17 over my axis
And when I say shape of objects internally we call this
map of an object and sometimes it's also referred to as a hidden class so since Javascript doesn't have
Classes, or didn't have classes until ES6 those are very different we call it
We give objects internally such a hidden internal class
Ok, so this is one way how we speed up the aid to do property accesses faster
That would not be yet to have a reactor immigrant in any reasonable time
What what any modern compiler has these days is at least?
two compilers a basic one and an optimizing compiler
in V8 we have actually two optimizing compilers at the moment the referred to as
crankshaft and Turbofan if you've ever come across that um
And so how that works is when you first run your program the basic compiler is trying to compile your code
very very fast
but too very
Naive machine code so it might not be super fast when you run your first executed
But after a while the basic compiler says well this function here that is executed all the time
we should really speed this up into better machine code so the optimizing compiler takes over and
recompiles a so-called hot function
into
Better machine code so you have more work because you have to recompile again
But you get much much faster codes when you run it a lot. It's worth it
and so if you combine
Optimization with these inline caches that's where you get a big big jump in in speed
Okay
So I hope you still with me. It's early um
if
If I lost you a little bit now would be a good time to get back um
I'm gonna show you no actual machine code for a simple function like that, so think about it you write
Javascript source code with cool frameworks and lots of stuff and everything's changing all the time everybody can put modules up
But when you compile it you get down to machine code
That's basically the same for decades, and I think it's really cool to see how like
The the high-level stuff what it ends up with in in machine code um
So just to recap
The Javascript engines they compile Javascript code down to machine code and I want to show you some machine code now
still for this load example
so this year is optimized for scene code for the simple load function that returns object at x and
It might look like a lot. I mean, it's a full page of code but for like low-level machine code
This is really not much, and I'm gonna show you what it actually does so up here. It says um
Call Stack check. This is where we entered a function?
We just have to make sure we don't have too much recursion recursion and we can still
Have space on the stack. So this is where we start the function
The next thing we do is a check nonce my sews my is
The aide internal language for a small integer we distinguish between small integers or objects on the heap
Anything that's an object must be on the heap if it's if it's a smile
You can check the hidden class of it or anything
So this is just a backup check basically making sure we we do deal with some kind of object internally
and now the
What the function should do now is get object that x and return that so what we do in this?
Optimized piece of machine code is a so called check maps and I said map is our word for
internal class or the shape of the object
So what this optimist machine code is doing now. It's comparing the two maps of
the
Parameter that you passed into the function
So that object has a map it's comparing that to the map that we saved in the inline cache when the basic
Compiler ran this before and if those are the same just like in our example before if those are the same
then we can do the
cheap fast property access which in this case is a load named fear you know I'll just load this field at the
specific offset and
Be done with it return it
now if those map checks
if if we call
The load function with an object now that looks very different
Then the map check would fail we don't have the same as that what we had on the cache
And we have to jump when we end up down here
which says the optimization bailout, so
You run your code you fill your cache
eventually you decide let's make really fast machine code you use the information from the cache to make this machine code like it's
Hard-Coded in there. It says check the map at exactly this address and
Now when you're running this code when you put objects in that are very different from what?
You are expecting from something you can't handle in the inline cache then you end up in Addy optimization
So that's where the optimizing compiler says I can handle this and you go back to the basic slower compiler
Okay, so um I said here. We make one map check because we had exactly one object in our cache
So we only compared to this one object um that's why we distinguish different states of inline caches
So we have if there's exactly one entry we call them monomorphic
If there's a handful like up to four entries
We call it
polymorphic and anything more as mega morphic and if you want if you can you want your code to have mostly monomorphic
Or maybe polymorphic caches but avoid the mega morphic
um
So here in this example that I just showed you there was one map check because the cache that we assumed the cash was
monomorphic if our cache is polymorphic and then we
Generate this optimized code um it would look like this
which is exactly the same except that it has
Four map checks in there we would compare against these four entries that we have in the cache now if it's mega morphic
We can't keep going on with all these branches and we have to do
Computationally more expensive things so that's why you want if possible always objects of the same shape
at the property accesses
So same game as before we are checking but if it matches one of the entries in the cache
Then we can just fast jump and return if it doesn't match any one of them. We're back to this deoptimization
Okay, and um you can actually try all of that
You can just take chrome that you have anyways and if you started from the command line
Be behind chrome just put this flag - those J's flags
Equals and then put the V8 flags that you want so for this case if you put print opt coat
Print optimized code you can also do a print code comments that gives you exactly this output
So you start chrome put this behind it open a website and your console will go full with like output like this oh
these flags
Okay
so we care about what the state of the inline caches is and if you want to dig a
Little Deeper in what's going on in your application?
we have a nice little tool for it ice the Icy explorer wenjian where you can explore the
states of your inline caches
You generate the output like I just said put the flags behind chrome and then load the file here
And you can group your inline caches very nicely by different keys
you really do want to use this tool not just the editor because
Here was compiling some type script, and it's a million entries. This is
Very nice if you get this grouped for you
You can sort by different things like here for example
I sorted by a code location and I drill down on the function that I saw earlier that had the
Exclamation mark so I can see exactly okay. What is happening at the property accesses in this function?
So nice little tool to see what are the inline caches doing because they affect the speed and the optimizations
There's also a nice overview if you want to see which functions are actually being optimized that micro
Kyla and any functions d optimize if you do tres opt and trace d upped you get this information, so
Here if we run an example that calls load eventually if you run it often enough, you'll see
Optimizing the function load, so the optimizing compiler
Recompiles it generates machine code similar to what we just saw
And then if you keep calling it and eventually call it with very different objects you will see D
optimizing evicting entry from the code database
So what's what's happening? Here is um
In this optimize machine code that I showed you when the map check didn't work out?
we jumped all the way to the bottom and said Bailout the optimization and
what we aide is doing here, it's
Deleting this optimize code because it figured well we optimized it, but it doesn't quite work, so we throw it away
We start over with the slow basic compiler for this function again
so
You don't want to see this too much when you profile your app because it slows it down
So back to this original problem where we saw the exclamation mark warning not optimized optimize too many times um
Now we have a better understanding of what's going on here
We have this function is related to there are things like property
Excesses in it we run this function with the basic compiler we put entries into our inline caches
And eventually we optimize it using the information from the inline cache, but then we run it with stuff that doesn't match
What's in the cache and we d optimize it and we run it again and a slow compiler eventually say oh
let's optimize it again, and then we do this ten times and eventually the compiler says no point in optimizing this because
Generating the optimized code of course costs performance
Let's just not optimize this function anymore. I give up so this is where this exclamation mark Comes from
And so by by looking at the cPU profile looking at the inline caches
Looking at optimized machine code
So non-optimized code and looking at the original Javascript code
It's possible to figure out what kind of changes to make to get rid of this optimization the optimization optimization
Do you have to mutation thing? So when you make those changes you profile again? You don't get the exclamation mark Anymore
okay um
General warning as always with optimizations be very very careful
only optimize if you really must if you have performance problems
And then if you do optimize make sure you really measure and find your bottlenecks
Don't blindly optimize don't say oh I've heard something about
Optimizing compilers gonna start changing because here I can tweak and in my cache or something
You just introduce bugs and make your code really hard to maintain
That's just the usual optimization um
but in this case specifically I
Would almost advise against optimizing for things like that because those are V8 internals. They're not
Agreed upon by the Acma Script Committee to be like this
and they change internally like
Every commit that we make every canary version you get every night things might have changed
We might have figured a better way to do something. So when you did micro optimizations for something that is true today
It might actually be
Negatively affecting your performance tomorrow
And then obviously it's just we ate the other Javascript engines work very differently
so if you write your Javascript code in a specific weight, and they're only
Faster and this one engine, but probably not in the other engines
So I hope I was able to give you a little bit of an insight into this
Black box of Javascript engines what they do from source code to really fast machine code
If you want to play with any of this yourself and see what uh what's my app doing in general?
Or what a little code Snippets doing?
You can always just use chrome started from the command Line - - - j as flag
equals and in some things we looked at was a trace of trace deopt print opcode or
Trace I see if you're familiar with node you can also
Start a node server and put the V8 flags here. Just put them right behind node
and if you were more adventurous
You can compile a V8 yourself and get D8 then it's the V8 debugging shell and run that with all the flags
um if you use D8 you have the advantage that you don't get the overhead of things that happen in the browser or
Things that happen in node before your function actually starts up and if you want to
Explore your inline caches the ICC explorer is distributed with the V8 source code
There's a link to it um if you have any questions or feedback or performance questions
Please find me during the breaks and feel free to reach out with Twitter or email. Thank you